[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild die beiden Angeklagten stehen
sichtbar unter Schock während Marvin n
mit hochrotem Gesicht vor sich hinstahrt
und den Kopf schüttelt bleibt
Todesfahrer Hamdi ha stehen erst reglos
mit gesenktem
dann schiebt er seinen Stuhl an den
Tisch stellt sich dahinter stützt die
Arme auf in seinem Gesicht zucken die
Muskeln dann bricht es aus ihm heraus
darf ich Richter ehestettt unterbricht
ihn so fort ich brauche keine
Unterhaltung der Angeklagte sagt nun
lauter was wollt ihr
denn diesmal beruhigen ihn seine
Verteidiger mit dieser ebehörten
Schilderung berichtet die Zeitung BZ im
Februar 2017 über das Urteil im
sogenannten
kudamraserprzess wir möchten euch heute
erzählen warum er die Menschen so bewegt
hat und weshalb er Rechtsgeschichte
schrieb ich bin Mirko Kasimir und ich
bin Stefan Netzeband hallo zusammen dass
der Tod eines unbeteiligten bei einem
illegalen Autorennen in Berlin zu einer
Anklage gegen die Rasa führte das war
damals natürlich nicht das über
aber das von Mord die Rede war das war
neu dieser raserfall hat in der Tat
Rechtsgeschichte geschrieben in
zweierlei Hinsicht erstens hat er die
Frage in den Mittelpunkt gestellt ob
jemand der besonders schnell Auto fährt
etwa hier um die Wette in Form einer Art
Autorennen diese Person in Kauf nimmt
dass Menschen in anderen Autos oder
vielleicht Fußgänger am Rande wenn Sie
getroffen werden wenn sie an einen
Unfall geraten und Sterben dass dann
Opfer eines Totschlags eines
vorsätzlichen Delikts oder sogar eines
vorsätzlichen Mordes werden das ist
Professor Martin Heger einer der
bekanntesten Strafrechtler in
Deutschland er hilft uns heute diesen
Fall juristisch einzuordnen und zu
verstehen aber erstmal reisen wir in der
Zeit zurück zum 1 Februar 2016
mir dieser 1 Februar ist ein
schmuddeliger Tag in Berlin immer wieder
gibt es regen die Temperaturen liegen um
die 7° in einer schishabar am äußersten
westlichen Ende des kurfürstendams
begegnen sich zwei Männer Hamdi ha aus
Berlin moabid damals 27 Jahre alt
Aushilfe bei einem Küchenbauer
zwischendurch immer wieder arbeitslos
und der 24-Jährige Marvin n aus der
Hochhaussiedlung marzan im Osten der
Hauptstadt er ist damals bei einem
Sicherheitsdienst
angestellt an diesem Abend wird er von
seiner 22-jährigen Freundin begleitet
eine Weile unterhalten sich die beiden
Männer man kennt sich als Fahrer
schneller Autos vom Sehen gegen :30 uh
verlassen Sie die Bar und steigen in
ihre Wagen
hamdih fährt einen getunen Audi A6 auf
den 12 Jahre alten Gebrauchtwagen hat er
lange gespart das Modell kostet in
diesem Alter und Zustand um die 10000 €.
Marvin n hat einen PS starken Mercedes
AMG der ist mit 60.000 bis 90.000 €
deutlich teurer n hat nach eigenen
Angaben jahrelang seinen Sold als
Berufssoldat für den Wagen gespart ein
paar 100 m östlich am
Adenauerplatz stehen die Autos kurz nach
0:40 Uhr nebeneinander an der Ampel auf
gegenseitige Handzeichen hin beginnen
die beiden Fahrer ein Autorennen
selbstverständlich illegal in Filmen wie
fast and furious ist das eine spannende
vielleicht sogar witzige Sache so ein
[Musik]
Autorennen aber die Realität in dieser
Februarnacht
a beide Wagen beschleunigen binnen
Sekunden auf mehr als 100 km pro Stunde
die Fahrer ignorieren jede einzelne rote
Ampel die jetzt folgt sie rasen unter
infernalem Motorenlärm über den Pam ein
Taxifahrer wird später Aussagen die
Sportwagen sei an ihm vorbeigezischt wie
Pfeile man habe keine Einzelheiten
erkennen
können nach knapp 2,5 km kommt es zur
Katastrophe unweit weltberühmten KDW wo
der kuhdam schon tunzenstraße heißt
biegt ein lilafarbener Jeep aus der
Nürnberger Straße darin der 69 Jahre
alte Arzt Michael warschitzki er
überquert die grüne Ampel
vorschriftsgemäß mit seinem Auto
warschitzki hat nur noch einen kurzen
Weg bis nach Hause der Mediziner hat
seine Praxis in der potsdammerstraße
unweit vom kudam waschitzkis Familie ist
jüdisch und in der Gemeinde bekannt und
beliebt zu seinen Patienten gehört auch
Rabbiner jehuda Teichtal eben sind noch
zwei Autos mit 160 bis 200 km/h vor
unserem geistigen Auge
[Musik]
vorbeigerast jetzt müssen wir auf
zeitlobe schalten um zu verstehen was
passiert der Audi von Hamdi h und der
Mercedes von Marvin n komm von Westen
her auf die Kreuzung zugerast für sie
zeigt die Ampel rot
von Süden nach Norden quert wie gesagt
bei grünen Michael waschitzki den town
Zen vielleicht sieht er aus dem
Augenwinkel etwas
heranrasen der Audi von HD h knallt in
den Jeep des Rentners der über 150 m
weit katapultiert
wird der Wagen bleibt zwischen Bordstein
und Straße auf der Seite liegen Marvin n
kann dem Crash vor ihm noch so eben
ausweichen und landet auf dem
Mittelstreifen der Einkaufsmeile wo
schwere Blumenkübel aus Beton eine
Durchfahrt versperren der Tacho des
Mercedes AMG bleibt bei 200
stehen Werbung so Mirko hier ist jetzt
mal ein Buchtipp angesagt oh das ist
eine sehr gute Idee ich suche nämlich
noch
Weihnachtsgeschenke ich auch mein lieber
und ich bin passenderweise auf eine
coole krimmy Reihe gestoßen od jetzt
machst du mich aber neugierig na sag mal
an ich schreib gleich mal mit also alle
Märchen Enden gut alle Märchen Enden nee
Stopp das ist nicht der Titel aber was
würdest du denn zu diesem Satz sagen
alle Märchen Enden gut na ja den halte
ich eher für ein Gerücht das stimmt doch
gar nicht dass alle Märchen gut enden
genau das ist eine Lüge und da sind wir
beim Titel Rotkäppchen lügt heißt das
Buch und mit dieser Lüge beginnt der
Auftakt einer Thriller Trilogie von
Bestseller Autor Elias
der kommt aus Moment Moment Moment warte
warte von dem habe ich gehört der ist
Polizist oder und der kommt aus meiner
alten Heimat Sachsen er kommt aus
Chemnitz glaube ich und er hat Bücher
geschrieben über einen Kommissar
namens Donner Erik Donner genau sehr gut
du bist gut Mirko Haller arbeitet seit
20 Jahren als Polizist und jetzt gibt es
eine Reihe mit der Sonderermittlerin
Nora rotmann vom Landeskriminalamt in
Berlin die stößt auf einen
Korruptionsverdacht rund um den früheren
LKA Präsidenten und dann bricht die
Hölle los wie ein blutdürstiger Wolf
zieht ein Killer durch die Hauptstadt
Berlin er fügt seinen Opfern
größtmögliche Schmerzen zu dabei
inszeniert er seine eigenen abartigen
märchenversion von Rotkäppchen denn
Rotkäppchen haben wir ja schon
festgestellt am Anfang Rotkäppchen hat
gelogen steefan das klingt wirklich sehr
spannend und nach einer guten
Inspiration für
Deutschland das finde ich auch also
Fälle innerhalb der Polizei sollten wir
mal nach guucken hier noch mal zum
Mitschreiben Rotkäppchen lügt der Auftag
zur grimtrilogie von Elias Haller ist am
10 Oktober rausgekommen und wenn euer
Interesse jetzt geweckt ist holt euch
das Buch gerne bei Amazon oder klickt
einfach auf den Link in unseren Show
nototes Werbung
Ende Michael warchitz in seinem
Geländewagen ist sofort tot beide Raser
sind verletzt worden Marvin NS
Mitfahrerin ist vom Geschehen so
geschockt dass sie in eine
psychiatrische Klinik gebracht wird
mitten in der dunklen regnerischen
Februarnacht ist der taunzien von
Blaulicht bestrahlt das
spezialunfallkommando der Berliner
Polizei vermisst jeden Flecken des
Unfallorts die beteiligten Autos werden
amtlich beschlagnahmt und
abtransportiert in dieser Nacht endet
das Leben des beliebten Berliner Arztes
Dr waschitz es endet aber auch die
Geduld der Öffentlichkeit mit
gewissenlosen Rasern denn dieser Unfall
der die beliebteste Einkaufsstraße
Berlins als Trümmerfeld voller Scherben
und Blut hinterlässt der ist ja nur der
Tiefpunkt jahrelanger Missstände hier
nur eine kleine
Auswahl 31 März 2001 in der Kölner
Innenstadt wird der Sohn des damaligen
Oberbürgermeisters Fritz schrammer
getötet Stefan Sch stand mit anderen
Fußgängern an einer roten Ampel als ein
Raser in die Gruppe fuhr
Ende 2006 bei einem illegalen Rennen
stirbt in Bochum ein
20jähriger am 14 April 2015 wieder Köln
eine 19-jährige Fahrradfahrerin wird bei
einem illegalen Straßenrennen zwischen
zwei jungen Männern so schwer verletzt
dass sie wenige Tage später
stirbt es sind mörderische Unfälle aber
bis hieren eben keine Morde Professor
Martin
Heger früher hat man das bewertet als
fahrlässige Tötung typischerweise dafür
war der Strafrahmen nicht besonders hoch
das Argument war eben immer wer auf der
Straße fährt auch wenn er zu schnell
fährt geht eigentlich nicht davon aus
dass er andere Menschen überfährt und
schon gar nicht dass er sie tötet auch
deshalb weil er natürlich selbst im Auto
ist und insbesondere wenn er mit anderen
Autofahrern kollidiert das auch für ihn
selbst ein erhebliches Risiko wäre gut
ein Jahr nach dem Unfall am Berliner
Kuhdamm müssen sich die beiden Fahrer
vor Gericht verantworten aber diesmal
geht es nicht um fahrlässige Tötung die
Kammer um Richter Ralf ehestedt wirft
den Rasern Mord vor die Argumentation
elektrisiert die Öffentlichkeit weit
über Berlin hinaus das Landgericht sagt
und der Bundesgerichtshof hat das dann
nach mehreren Schleifen letztlich
bestätigt dass jemand der ein Autorennen
fährt gegen einen anderen mitten durch
die Stadt und andere Autos können dazu
kommen können quer kommmen sozusagen
dass diese Person trotz der möglichen
Eigengefährdung billigend in Kauf nimmt
eine andere Person zu überfahren in
ihrem Auto oder als Fußgänger und dass
damit Tötungsvorsatz gegeben ist damit
kommt eine Bestrafung wegen fahlässiger
Tötung nicht in Betracht es ist
mindestens ein Totschlag im deutschen
Strafgesetzbuch es ist aber eben auch
möglich dass dieser Totschlag sogar als
Mord gewertet wird wenn neben dem
Tötungsvorsatz auch ein sogenanntes
Mordmerkmal bejahrt wird und das hat die
Rechtssprechung hier auch gemacht vor
allem hat sie gesagt die Nutzung eines
Autos ist ein
gemeingefährliches Mittel und wenn ich
jemanden mit einem gemeingefährlichen
Mittel töte dann ist das ein Mord bildtv
mit Moderator Moritz Wedel berichtet am
Tag des Urteils live Hamid h und Marvin
n Rasen mit ihren hochgetunen Autos mit
170 Stunden Kilom über den kudam
überfahren mehrere rote Ampeln ein Audi
A6 mit 225 PS ein AMG Mercedes 380 PS
liefern sich ein Rennen als der Rentner
mich mich W bei Grün mit seinem Jeep aus
einer Seitenstraße auf den kudam fährt
hamita kracht ungebremst in das Auto des
Rentners tötet ihn sofort Mord sagte
heute das Gericht ihre Autos waren
Waffen und bei 160 und 170
stundenkilomet ja da haben die beiden
bingend in Kauf genommen dass andere
Verkehrsteilnehmer bei ihrer irrsinnigen
Fahrt über den Kuh am sterben also jetzt
das Urteil Mord und deshalb
lebenslänglich die Sprecherin des
Gerichts und die Staatsanwaltschaft das
ist das Wesentliche geht davon aus dass
die Angeklagten bewusst billigend den
Kauf genommen haben dass ein
unbeteiligter Verkehrsteilnehmer zu Tode
kommen könnte bei dieser ganzen Aktion
ja und der Staatsanwaltschaft zeigte
sich zufrieden nach diesem Urteil und
hofft auf eine abschreckende Wirkung ich
erhoffe mir natürlich wie mit jedem
Urteil il dass man hier erstreitet in
eine Stück weit auch eine abschreckende
Wirkung gegenüber denjenigen Personen
die sich vielleicht mit dem Gedanken
tragen eine solche Straftat zu begehen
vielleicht auch damit dem gedankenragen
einen Straßenrennen durchzuführen dass
ich vielleicht einige von diesen oder
das das Urteil einige die Personen von
diesem Geiser
abschrecken das juristische hin und her
das auf dieses Urteil folgte können wir
abkürzen auch nach weiteren Instanzen
blieb es bei der Neuerung mit dem
mautvorwurf Todesfahrer Hamdi h wurde
also letztendlich wegen Mordes zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt Marvin n
wegen versuchten Mordes zu 13
Jahren ich habe muss ich sagen durch
diese Episode wieder was gelernt denn
das Urteil das habe ich zwar damals
mitbekommen auch als Journalist
natürlich aber die Begründung die ist
echt ein bisschen tricky finde ich den
Rasern wird nicht wie ich immer dachte
eine Art Vorsatz vorgeworfen denn den
hatten sie ja ehrlicherweise auch nicht
ihnen wird vorgeworfen dass sie den Tod
von Menschen in Kauf nahmen und ihre
Autos dabei als gemeingefährliche Waffen
dienten und allein dies diese Wertung
des Autos als Waffe das hat die Urteile
ermöglicht Jurist Heger findet das
übrigens nicht ganz
unproblematisch da bin ich persönlich
etwas unsicher weil ich das Gefühl habe
ein gemeingefährliches Mittel ist der
Sache nach etwas was völlig un krolliert
eine Vielzahl von Menschen erfasst das
werden Bombe Rakete vielleicht wenn ich
im Haus im Erdgeschoss eines Hochhaus
Feuer lege oder so während das
Autorennen und das zeigt ja dieser Fall
auch doch typischerweise eine Person
betrifft einen Fußgänger oder einen
anderen kraftfahrzeugfahrer vielleicht
zwei wenn da doch der Beifahrer drin
sitzt deshalb bin ich in diesen Fällen
etwas unsicher ob das wirklich über
überzeugend sein soll das auch als Mord
zu
bestrafen ich finde das Urteil auch
spannend denn einerseits ist natürlich
klar dass es richtig und wichtig ist
wenn Raser von illegalen Rennen
abgehalten werden allerdings wirft die
Debatte meiner Meinung nach noch die
Frage auf wie die Definition von
gemeingefährlichen Waffen eigentlich
genau zu interpretieren ist und wie sie
z.B bei Verkehrsverstößen wie fahren mit
überhöhter Geschwindigkeit gewertet wird
ob das dazu beiträgt unser Straßen vor
illegalen Rennen zu schützen das wird
sich zeigen müssen gute Hinweise und
Einwende merko aber diese Gefahr sieht
Jura Professor Heger tatsächlich nicht
grundsätzlich wer einfach zu schnell
fährt was fast alle mal machen in ihrem
Leben und dadurch einen Unfall baut wird
weiterhin nur wegen vahlässiger Tötung
bestraft werden vorausgesetzt aus dem
Unfall resultiert der Tod des
Unfallgegners das folgt daraus dass dies
diese Person wie wir im Rechtssinne
sagen nicht in Kauf nimmt jemanden zu
überfahren und damit zu töten und man
kann sich das Ganze umgekehrt vorstellen
wenn man dieser Person sagt diesem
einfach nur zu Schnellfahrer sagt
würdest du auch fahren wenn du wüsstest
dass du einen Unfall baust dann würde
wohl sagen nein also fassen wir am Ende
noch mal zusammen was wir heute über
Rasen und Mord gelernt haben mit den
Hinweisen von Professor Heger aktoren
gehören laut Strafgesetzbuch zu einem
Mord
Mordlust Befriedigung des
Geschlechtstriebes Habgier
Heimtücke Grausamkeit gemeingefährliche
Mittel Ermöglichung einer anderen
Straftat Verdeckung einer anderen
Straftat verwerfliche
Absicht aber es braucht für einen
Schuldspruch natürlich nicht alle auf
einmal es ist möglich dass in einem Fall
mehr als ein Mordmerkmal theoretisch
sogar eine Anzahl verwirklicht sind aber
das ist nicht nötig ein Mord ist schon
dann gegeben wenn auch nur ein
Mordmerkmal nachgewiesen werden kann und
das war hier zumindest in den ersten
Fällen die die gemeingefährlichkeit der
Begehung das war also unser Fall für
heute wir haben ihn mit Hilfe der
gesammelten Artikel der BZ erzählt und
mit Professor Heger gibt uns gerne mal
Feedback wie euch diese juristischen
Hinweise und Erklärungen gefallen
schreibt uns z.B unter
podcast@bild.de oder schickt uns eine
WhatsApp Nachricht an
685 1138 diese Nummer packen wir auch
noch mal in die Show Notes genauso wie
die
E-Mailadresse Aufnahme und Skript Stefan
Netzeband Postproduktion durch schwarz
audio berlin wir freuen uns wenn ihr
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei
seid euer under
dir hat diese Folge von tout Deutschland
gefallen du bekommst von True Crime
einfach nicht genug dann hör jetzt in
unsere weiteren Folgen rein hier warten
mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf dich
wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca Rusch
der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder die
Entführung von ursela Hermann wir hören
uns bei Tat Deutschland